[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the head coach of the washington
football team he's ron rivera
after the big win over pittsburgh
putting an end to their
undefeated season next game will be
sunday against the 49ers
hi coach how's morale good it's going
real good
i was wondering i was looking back
through your stats now you played
linebacker
did you have one touchdown in your
career yes yes my uh second year super
bowl season against detroit
and what do you remember about that i
remember scooping it up and
uh and just sprinting the entire four
and a half yards
do you have that football yes oh yeah
almost certainly
but did somebody else on the defense do
the damage and then you just cleaned up
the leftovers is that what happened
oh yeah hall of famer richard dent uh
stripped them and
the ball just bounced nice and i scooped
it perfectly
how would you compare that team with
like the steel curtain like the greatest
defenses of all time
and and maybe you know your territorial
and i understand i think the steel
curtain was the best defense i ever saw
but you you know it's interesting if you
compare it by
by the way they play during their their
era
i i think you you have a chance to to
say which was better
for that era um and and
to me i i do think the steel curtain was
was one because
you know they they they won more than
one super bowl if we'd want a second one
i believe me i i would be i would fight
everybody
tooth and nail but because we only won
the one i i
i'm a little hesitant um but i i still
think we are the best but
i'm i'm a little hesitant to get into
those big fights and arguments over it
if i you could add anybody to your
roster your defense from the 85 bears
oh without a doubt uh
mike singletary because
mike made it mike made guys around him
better um
he he he he he he had a way that that he
did things he did things the right way
and it kind of spilled over to his
teammates he played the right way
and it helped elevate other people's
games you know
because when to me when when you have a
linebacker whether it's a middle
linebacker
or one of the other inside guys or
willer sam
those guys that play to a specific level
and play a specific way
they can raise those guys around them um
more so i think than any other position
on defense i thought mike tomlin had an
interesting
uh conversation with chase young after
the game i
i think he basically says my teams
aren't bad enough
to get a guy as good as you in the draft
i i'm paraphrasing here but it feels
like that that's what he was saying with
chase young that's a pretty good
compliment there
it is it's a very good compliment and
and you know chase is one of those guys
because
you know not only is he is he going to
in my opinion he'll be a very good
football player in this league and have
a chance to have a hall of fame career
he has he plays at an energy level um an
excitement
that that i think really again gets his
teammates fired up and
and that's one of the things i think is
really neat about him is he he doesn't
know any different that's just the way
he is and so his it's his whole
approach to the game he loves the game
you should have seen him at pre-game
warm-up
um you know because we were talking
about some of the guys on the other team
and he said oh my god i gotta go over
and say hi to ben i
gotta shake ben's hand i said really
goes oh man are you kidding i i grew up
watching him play it was
i mean he was so fired up and and then
when ben got close he ran over there
and introduced himself shook ben's hand
and he's just he said man i just i had
to do that coach
i said all right no that's when you say
introduce yourself after you've sacked
him okay
but you know what that's i left that to
one of the other coaches to say
okay the philosophy going into this
you know the steelers they don't have a
great running game right now
and right you knew ben was going to
throw a lot but what was
what was the defensive philosophy
against the steelers
well it was was to make sure we we we
could shut the run down
to to get it to a point where where they
were one-dimensional and i get it they
weren't missing their best run they were
missing their best runner
uh and and and some of their offensive
lineman but you know we still felt that
if we could stop the run
and and get them to be where they were
one dimensional we we really felt we had
a really good opportunity
when did you know you were going to win
that game um
wow uh i would i would say probably
middle of the fourth quarter
um you know we took the lead felt really
comfortable about it
got an opportunity to extend the lead
but i'd say middle of the fourth quarter
just the
the energy the vibe everything was going
in the right direction what was it like
in the locker room after the win
it was cool it was i mean it was it it's
it's it's one of those things that you
you remember it's one of those things
that you truly appreciate
and you don't get it unless you've been
in the locker room and i'm telling you
it was pandemonium
the guys were excellent i mean i'm so
happy for those guys because
you know a lot of them have gone through
a lot for the last few years a lot of
them went through a lot
you know this this off season having to
to take all the body blows that
this team took you know from from
everything from the
the the um the social issues
to the uh the naming to to to those
those articles that came out um there
was just a lot and
and this really i think was if you could
feel the energy that they were releasing
you would almost think god they're just
letting a lot of steam off right now
what did you think when you saw alex
smith's bloody ankle
i thought oh goodness and then i
realized it was his it was his it was
his
it was his left leg not his right and
then thought okay he's got
he got cleated i mean because believe me
i i can remember
bleeding through my socks you know and
and knowing that you know hey
i'd gotten cleated so that's when i said
okay
just for a brief second and then i
realized it was his left leg
i thought the same thing because i i
started taking inventory and i go oh my
god what what leg what leg what leg
and then i realized and then i was like
i mean he got cleated which hurts
but you know what he's been through
we're going oh yeah he just got cleated
and he's bleeding there
not not not a big deal i when you uh
when do you start to assess the
quarterbacking situation though
in the future you know as a head coach
as a team
given alex's age um yep kyle allen
dwayne haskins
like nope i mean that that's definitely
something
we're talking about right now because
again you know
you you hate to be in the quarterback
business because because that means
you're you're trying to find one
and right now we're feeling really good
about what we're getting from alex the
leadership we've gotten from him
um and also what he's doing in helping
to develop the rest of the team
i mean we got a group of young wide
receivers that really seem to be taking
the next step we have a tight end and
logan thomas that's
really starting to come into his own uh
we've got some young running backs
that are getting opportunities that he's
helping to to develop and we've got an
offensive line that we've kind of put
together
and and those guys seem to play
accordingly because of of what he's done
and because we control the ball um
better the defense isn't on the field as
long
you know what i'm saying so it's helped
the defense as well
so it it it's you know we're we'll have
a lot of conversations going into the
the the off season i mean it it's
something we really have to discuss and
then we got to see how alex is feeling
once the season's over as well
you'll appreciate this my heisman trophy
pick
a few years ago was your tight end
oh really yes when he was at virginia
tech i thought they were going to run
the table
i loved logan thomas i said i remember i
i thought man he's going to be like that
now is he an emergency quarterback at
all like is he is he fourth string
yes he's he's he's the emergency guy on
the field for us
um you know we go into games with two so
he's actually third string
and um and we had a little taste of it
against uh dallas on on thanksgiving day
when he uh he ran the titan reverse pass
and hit terry mclaurin downfield
oh yeah i know my guys still don't let
them
they don't let me forget the oh yeah
logan thomas yeah
heisman the fact that he's playing in
the nfl i deserve a little credit for
that i think
just a little bit let me i'll tell you
right now you talk about a smart
football player i mean he gets it he
understands it
and because of it i think it's helped
him at the position of tight end right
now
can you out bench any of your starters
on defense
not anymore okay not anymore i'm just
curious about no
at your peak though oh i had a chance
i would have had a chance what about on
offense you can you can out bench alex
smith right
um i'll tell you what now he's a warrior
inside the weight room are you kidding
oh my god wait what's a warrior in the
weight room mean
a guy that just slings it he's around
just fighting the way i mean he is
he's impressive i mean i tell you we've
got some guys that are that
that really are our our war daddies when
they get into the weight room
that's an impressive thing to watch
isn't it great we're not talking about
your health
yes it is thank goodness ever and i
really do mean that i mean i've been
very fortunate thank you yeah well
the holidays should be a whole lot
better uh tied for first in the nfc east
you got the niners coming up more
importantly uh
you look great sound great and uh we
appreciate your time as always coach
thanks dan appreciate you that's ron
rivera head coach of the washington
football team